Entertainers spend more time on the road then
they do in their own element.
And sometimes in the quest for comfort, actors
demand some outlandish stuff to make the journey
feel more homey.
But occasionally, there’s something else
driving the drama.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Famous Actors
Who Were EXTREMELY High Maintenance On Set.
Tom Cruise
Tom Cruise has headlined some of the most
successful movies in history.
And while films like Jerry Maguire and A Few
Good Men gave him a chance to flex his acting
chops, his career choices have mostly revolved
around action.
In fact, he’s one of the only people in
Hollywood who performs the majority of his
own stunts.
How does he do it?
With a thong.
Apparently the actor has been wearing custom
thongs under his wardrobe for years.
And the wardrobe department of every movie
he works on has to have about 50 of the undergarments
on hand at all times.
Far be it for us to judge anyone's choice
of underpants, and Cruise swears by them.
The actor cites their flexibility and comfort
as reasons for his thong passion, but we know
he was probably just trying to avoid those
unsightly panty lines.
Lindsay Lohan
Since the age of three, Lindsay Lohan has
been in and out of the spotlight; modelling,
singing, and acting.
Her big break came after starring in the 1998
remake of The Parent Trap.
But going from Disney to DUI, Lindsay Lohan
devolved into a punchline rapidly after she
hit peak fame with 2004’s Mean Girls.
Following a string of public embarrassments,
the actress was hired by director Paul Schrader
for his 2013 film The Canyons.
Lohan was actually fired from the production
before it even began, but was re-hired thanks
to a 90-minute drunken tantrum she threw outside
the director’s hotel room door.
Failing to show up for rehearsals, refusing
to change her makeup, and reckless drinking
jeopardized the entire shoot.
Plus, her $600 sushi lunches put an extra
strain on an already low budget.
George Clooney
When you’re as bankable as George Clooney,
there’s not much people wouldn’t do to
make sure you’re happy on set.
The Kentucky native has been in the biz for
over three decades, and has made quite a name
for himself.
And while he’s generally regarded as a pretty
down to earth guy, he apparently had a few
grand requests while filming the 2013 smash
Gravity.
It seems the actor wanted to make his trailer
a bit more homey.
And requested a custom beach hut, basketball
court, and hot tub be within close proximity
to his quarters.
A lofty price to pay considering his limited
screen time in the final product.
Marlon Brando
Marlon Brando is one of the greats.
And depending on who you ask, he might me
THE great.
A Hollywood heavy-hitter, The Godfather appeared
in more than 40 movies.
And despite his passing in 2004, remains a
household name to this day.
But nearing the end of his career, the actor
quickly lost passion for the job.
Brando was notoriously difficult to work with
on 1979’s Apocalypse Now, but director John
Frankenheimer experienced the worst of it
while making The Island of Dr. Moreau.
Brando showed up with an ice bucket on his
head and refused to take it off.
He also insisted that a dwarf appear in every
one of his scenes.
And in a move that would impress any fifth
grader, even had his doctor write a note proclaiming
that Brando was allergic to Frankenheimer.
Classy.
Jennifer Aniston
Filmmaking is a team sport, but Jennifer Aniston
insists on remaining solo.
Stories from previous productions paint the
actress as standoffish.
Saying that when everyone else was eating
lunch together, Aniston took off to her private
trailer and refused to speak to the crew.
She wouldn’t ride in the production vehicles
either, and required her own personal SUV
and driver to shuttle her around the set.
Other reports have surfaced claiming that
whenever the actress snaps her fingers, one
of her underlings will run to ice her forehead
so she doesn’t get too hot.
It’s one person’s job to follow Aniston
with a fan, so wherever she is she’s temperature-controlled.
Like a fridge.
Jack Nicholson
Jack Nicholson’s been a cinematic fixture
since the sixties.
And one of only two actors to be nominated
for an Academy Award every decade since he
started working.
And those bragging rights mean that the actor
gets away with some questionable behavior.
While working on the Martin Scorsese-directed
The Departed in 2006, he decided to go off
script.
Since Scorsese has tons of experience working
with moody artistic-types, he’s seen it
all before.
Nicholson was adamant about including a scene
where his character snorts coke off an actress’
backside.
And the ideas didn’t stop there.
The actor was apparently passionate about
including a sex toy in the scene for no reason,
other than it amused him.
obviously the director was cool with the suggestions,
as both made it into the final cut of the
film.
Will Smith
Ever since the Fresh Prince of Bel-Air moved
to Hollywood, he’s been making headlines.
And while some people argue that Will Smith
hasn’t done a good movie since 2006, 2012’s
Men In Black 3 made a lot of the franchise’s
fans ecstatic.
But during production, some citizens of New
York felt eclipsed by the actor’s presence.
Despite his home being only a few blocks away,
Smith insisted on staying in a double-decker
trailer.
Allegedly, it was so tall that it turned a
normally sunny community into a patch of shade,
and blocked out the sun for the entirety of
filming.
Presumably leaving behind legions of dead
houseplants in his wake.
Jennifer Lopez
Everyone has a favorite color and Jennifer
Lopez’s is white.
Apparently the dancer-turned-actress-turned-singer-turned-actress
likes everything in her dressing room to be
pristine white.
Furniture, drapes, candles, you name it: white.
Reports have surfaced that Lopez doesn’t
like eye contact either, and only speaks through
her entourage.
Jenny from the block doesn’t forget about
her friends, either.
And, in addition to her salary, demands private
planes and rooms for her entire team of handlers.
Apparently the diva attitude isn’t even
new, and stories of her antics go all the
way back to her time as a dancer on In Living
Color.
Wesley Snipes
According to Patton Oswalt, the making of
Blade: Trinity was a gong-show.
And Wesley Snipes was the reason.
The relationship between Snipes and director
David Goyer turned volatile almost instantly,
and the two men came to blows.
After Goyer hired some badass looking dudes
to come to set one day, Snipes holed up in
his trailer.
And would only communicate via post-it notes
that he signed with his character’s name.
Oswalt mentioned how Snipes felt slighted
in the paycheck department, and would smoke
pot in his trailer all day as retaliation.
Emerging only for closeups, the majority of
the actor’s slack was picked up by his body
double, and co-star Ryan Reynolds- who apparently
got most of his characters lines thanks to
Snipes’ bad attitude.
And the final movie might actually be better
for it.
Jared Leto
Jared Leto fancies himself a method actor.
Which is usually all well and good, until
the character he’s tasked to play is a green-haired
violent psychopath.
On the set of the upcoming Suicide Squad,
the actor fully immersed himself in the role.
He’s almost unrecognizable as The Joker,
so much so that his cast mates have admitted
to being freaked out by his mere presence.
Will Smith has even stated that he’s never
met the Jared Leto underneath the costume,
only The Joker.
His costars were even afraid of him.
Sending gifts of dead animals, used condoms,
and sex toys to his peers didn’t make him
any friends either.
So what do you think of our list?
Do you know of other actors who were extremely
high maintenance on set?
Tell us about them in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.